und damit hallöchen meiner lieben freund
und herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
weiteren mord vorstellung heute am
montag ich bin wieder am videos
vorproduzieren und habe mir gedacht so
wie wir erst einmal weitere mod und zwar
just any major players motto es ist eine
modifikation die leider nur für die 1
punkt 6 punkt 4 fort und die 1.7.2011
punkt 7.10 und erst recht nicht für die
1.84 als punkt 18 jahre erst voll wenig
geile motzing verfügbar kommt mir so vor
jedenfalls schon was die mode macht und
zwar wenn ihr mal genau hinschauten
richtig mit dem ganzen körper mit den
füßen nicht ge hoch wie sonst was auch
wenn ich springe seht ihr hier so
springe ich fliege beispielsweise sieht
so aus als würde ich durch die luft rein
mehr oder weniger ich gehe mal hier
wieder runter und auch wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal blogger seht
ihr schon der ganze körper blockt es ist
halt einfach so minecraft mit besseren
animationen auch wenn ich beispielsweise
jetzt mal da hinten in der 2
seht ihr hier halt schon wie ich
schwimme also springe jetzt
beispielsweise mal rein und ihr seht
schon wenn ich quasi einfach nur so
untergehen oder so dann bewege ich meine
arme hat dementsprechend nicht wenn ich
dann allerdings myspace druck oder space
gedrückt halte dann ist er die ganze
zeit mit seinen händen wirklich diese
diese wie nennt man dass diese engels
bewegung kraulen die kraul in ist ja
wenn man solche habe überhaupt keine
ahnung ist einfach immer alle schwimmen
halt und sieht halt alles viel cooler
aus ich fühle mich irgendwie gerade wie
so ein fisch auf dem trockenen so wie
das ganze aussieht aber es ist halt
schon recht nah es ist halt einfach
minecraft einen besseren animationen
also ich weiß viele sagen sie ja mein
kopf das ist so wie es ist da brauchen
wir nicht viele animationen und sowas
aber ich finde sowas ist gerade ganz
geil gemacht und zwar schuldig dass man
das halt einfach extrem cool wenn da
jemand so oft ich zustimmen so das ist
halt einfach viel cooler die hit box
verändert sich dementsprechend und so
weiter und so fort und was ich euch
eigentlich noch zeigen wollte ist meine
lieben freunde ich kann meine maske dann
so ein bisschen wenn ich die maske ab
hätte würde man meine augen hat auch
animiert sehen erst mal freunde wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise sieht das ganze
auch so aus als ich stehe dann halt so
ein bisschen im block drin aber sieht so
aus als würde ich quasi gleich ein paar
kilos laufen
ok so ein bisschen verkrüppelt sieht
schon aus aber was ihr euch eigentlich
sagen wollte ist es gibt noch etwas was
ich mit meinen augen machen kann und
mein mund und zwar wenn ich quasi ganz
schnell auf versteht auf dem forum
artikel dann ist er halt so richtig mit
dem monster und wenn ich beispielsweise
hungrig bin dann dann schaut also ein
bisschen traurig wenn er aggressiv ist
also wenn er beispielsweise angegriffen
wir oder irgendwie sonst was mit ihm
passiert dann sieht er halt so ein
bisschen so die augenbrauen so ein
bisschen so sieht er dann aus allerdings
kann ich euch das ganze nicht zeigen
weil ich gerade eine maske auf habe
warum heißt die nummer zwei warum liegt
durch stroh
ich würde euch das echt unglaublich
gerne zeigen und ich habe auch schon
mehrmals seit zwei stunden versucht mein
skin zu updaten und es ging auch alles
also dass in der 1.8 hatte ich ja den
steves kind vielleicht könnt euch an die
commands folge gestern erinnern wo ich
den steves genannt hatte allerdings bin
ich dann mal in die 1.6 punkt 4 nämlich
dass hier gerade auf bin ich da mal rein
gegangen und habe ich immer noch dieses
kind weil auf der minecraft website
steht das ist bei allen versionen unter
1.7 länger dauern könnte das des kindes
change the weekend ist wahrscheinlich
von den von der ganz normalen minecraft
1.8 version geht doch die website drauf
und können dementsprechend dort dann
einfach so sagen ja ich hätte gern
dieses gen diesem skin dieses können und
dann wird er direkt geupdatet innerhalb
von wenigen sekunden bei der 16.4 kannst
allerdings mehrere stunden dauern hat mo
yan auf der website veröffentlicht das
ist natürlich cool dass diese mod gerade
in der 106 punkte von mir aufgenommen
wird weil ich keine 17.24 stadt hatte
und ich habe jetzt auch keine lust das
ganze noch mal neu zu installieren also
ich möchte euch jetzt einfach mal sagen
wenn ich hungrig bin oder so dann
verändert sich die augenbrauen und der
mund und wenn ich wütend bin und wenn
ich etwas toll finde dann gehen die
augenbrauen halt so wenn ich etwas nicht
so toll findet so und ja das ist auch
eigentlich schon alles von dieser
modifikation heute nun etwas kürzeres
video und
er brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht
sagen
irgendwie fühle ich mich richtig scheiße
weil diese modifikation schon sehr alt
ist und weil sie auch sehr klein ist und
ich fühle mich echt immer blöd wenn ich
selber nicht mit dem video zufrieden bin
ich hoffe euch jetzt trotzdem gefallen
ich wollte euch halt nur noch mal zeigen
weil ich bin halt wirklich wieder übers
wochenende in bielefeld beim 1 parent
und die osterfeiertage und so deswegen
bin ich am vorproduzieren deswegen
dachte jetzt einfach für den montag hier
so eine kleine modifikation einfach mal
raus asseln ich hoffe euch hat ist
trotzdem gefallen wenn es denn getan hat
dann würde ich mich über eine bewertung
wenn ihr irgendeine irgendwelche
modifikation kennt die vielleicht klein
sind allerdings über die man viel
erzählen kann und die echten eis sind
dann einfach mal in die kommentare
spammen und dann werde ich die eventuell
auch mal vorstellen und sorry dass das
video hat heute nur so kurz war und ohne
inhalt wirklich aber die nächsten tage
mal wieder coole videos habe ich extrem
coole sachen geplant ja dafür kommen
einfach ein paar sachen ich hoffe euch
aufgefallen wir sehen uns irgendwann
anders wieder